Yesterday, a Muslim terrorist named
Mohammad Diallo, a naturalized citizen
from Sierra Leone, opened fire at Old
Dominion University in Norfolk,
Virginia, killing one person and
injuring two more.
He would have done far more damage, but
the students in the classroom charged
him and beat and stomped and stabbed him
to death.
Uh the There were students that were in
that room that subdued him and uh
rendered him no longer
alive. I don't know how else to say it,
but they basically uh were able to
terminate the threat.
So, he was not shot? He was not shot.
I went to college at Old Dominion
University. I did a double major in
biology and philosophy before heading
off to graduate school. I met Nabeel at
ODU. I met my wife at ODU. My wife and I
had our first son while we were students
at ODU.
Most Americans remember where they were
on 9/11. I was in the parking lot at ODU
listening to the radio as the second
tower came crashing to the ground. I
started writing articles about Islam
while I was at ODU.
And now we've got jihadis screaming
Allahu Akbar and shooting professors at
ODU.
I can tell you that we have confirmed
reports that prior to him conducting
this act of terrorism, he shouted Allahu
stated Allahu Akbar.
Let's take a closer look at what
happened and learn a bit more about the
shooter and see if we can figure out
what motivated him.
Mohammad Diallo didn't wake up recently
and decide to be a terrorist. He's been
on the FBI's radar for a while.
Um and he was formerly a
uh subject of a FBI investigation in
material supporting terrorism.
In 2017, he was sentenced to 11 years in
prison for providing material support to
ISIS.
What kind of aid was he giving to ISIL
10 years ago?
Uh he wanted to conduct a terrorist
attack similar to that in Fort Hood,
Texas.
He wanted to carry out something similar
to the Fort Hood massacre. That tells
you a lot
of what you'd want to know about him.
There are different kinds of jihadis.
There are jihadis who only want to
target soldiers or future soldiers. They
target military bases or military
events. That's what US Army Major Nidal
Hasan did at Fort Hood in 2009.
Then there are jihadis who don't care if
they're killing soldiers as long as
they're killing non-Muslims, but they
don't, under any circumstances, want to
kill practicing Muslims.
These jihadis target concerts or
Christmas markets because they don't
think any real Muslims will be there.
And there are jihadis who don't mind
killing Muslims as long as the Muslims
are collateral damage. They'll target
places like the World Trade Center,
knowing that Muslims will be killed in
the attack, but they believe it's
acceptable.
Mohammad Jalloh wanted to kill US
soldiers or future US soldiers, even
though he used to be in the Virginia
Army National Guard. The Associated
Press reports
Jalloh, a former Virginia Army National
Guard member who authorities said was
taking online classes at the university,
killed one person and injured two other
people in Thursday's shooting. ROTC
students subdued and killed him.
Jalloh was in the National Guard and he
targeted an ROTC class. ROTC stands for
Reserve Officers Training Corps. It's a
college program for students who intend
to become officers in the military.
Little is publicly known about Diallo,
who was a naturalized citizen from
Sierra Leone. But court documents depict
him as a troubled man who was
radicalized by Anwar al-Awlaki,
a well-known American Imam who became an
al-Qaeda propagandist.
The Virginia Army National Guard
confirmed he served as a specialist from
2009 until 2015 when he was honorably
discharged. Diallo told a government
informant he quit the National Guard
after hearing lectures from al-Awlaki,
according to a 2016 FBI affidavit filed
in his criminal case.
In a letter to the federal judge that
presided over his sentencing, Diallo
wrote,
"I feel deep regret in having been
driven by my emotions rather than my
intellect and becoming involved with
such an evil organization.
I reject and deplore terrorism and any
groups associated with it, especially
ISIL."
Good to know he was vehemently opposed
to terrorism when he was being
sentenced.
So,
he was in the Virginia Army National
Guard for years from 2009 until 2015. He
started listening to the lectures of
al-Qaeda terrorist Anwar al-Awlaki, who,
by the way, was educated at Colorado
State University, San Diego State
University, and George Washington
University.
Strange how these guys can be walking
among us for years before they start
killing.
Diallo soon concluded that as a Muslim,
he shouldn't be part of the US military.
On the contrary, he should attack the US
military. So, he left the National Guard
and began plotting his attack.
Fortunately, he made the classic jihadi
blunder back in 2016. He started
blabbing his plans to other people.
Jallow's October 2016 plea came after a
3-month sting operation in which he,
then 26, confessed to an undercover FBI
agent that he was thinking about
carrying out an attack similar to the
2009 shootings at Fort Hood, which left
13 people dead. Authorities launched the
2016 operation after Jallow made contact
with members of the Islamic State group
in Africa earlier that year.
Jallow later told the informant that the
Islamic State group had asked if he
wanted to participate in an attack. He
tried to donate $500 to the group, but
the money actually went to an account
controlled by the FBI, according to
court documents. Jallow then tried to
buy an AR-15 assault rifle from a
Virginia gun store, but was turned away
because he lacked the proper paperwork.
The affidavit says he returned the next
day and bought a different assault
rifle.
Prosecutors said the rifle was rendered
inoperable before Jallow left the store,
unbeknownst to Jallow. He was arrested
the following day.
He was arrested. That's when he suddenly
realized that terrorism is wrong.
And he blamed depression and drugs
following a difficult breakup with his
girlfriend. Seems like the judge bought
it.
US District Judge Liam O'Grady, an
appointee of former President George W.
Bush, sentenced him instead to 11 years
in prison with credit for time served in
jail since his July 2016 arrest. The
judge also ordered Jallow to participate
in a program for substance abuse testing
and treatment, mental health treatment,
and requested that he be evaluated for
the federal prison system's residential
drug program.
Completing the residential drug abuse
program can reduce an inmate's prison
sentence by up to a year, according to
the Federal Bureau of Prisons. Normally,
inmates serving sentences for
terrorism-related offenses aren't
eligible for the program. In addition,
some inmates who stay out of trouble in
prison can reduce their sentence by
earning up to 54 days of good conduct
time credit for each year of their
sentence. However, under the 2018 prison
reform law, known as the First Step Act,
inmates convicted of terrorism-related
offenses are not eligible for such
credit.
Whatever happened, he got released early
and decided to go on a killing spree at
Old Dominion University. He went looking
for the ROTC class and shot the
professor.
Tonight, we've confirmed Lieutenant
Colonel Brandon Shaw, shown in this
photo on the Old Dominion University
website, is the man who Muhammad Jalloh
killed in the shooting rampage. Colonel
Shaw was a professor of military science
and department chair at the university's
ROTC program. The FBI says a group of
ROTC students stepped in and killed
Jalloh. These are the court sketches
from 2016 when Jalloh was convicted of
trying to provide material to support
the Islamic State of Iraq. He was
formally in the Army National Guard. He
pled guilty, was sentenced to 11 years
in prison, but was reportedly released
in December of 2024. This is now being
investigated as an act of terrorism. The
life of this man taken, the veteran Army
pilot surviving combat missions in the
Middle East during the early 2000s, only
to be killed here on US soil. And there
could have been other casualties if it
were not for those brave students
confronting the attacker and ending his
life as he tried to end theirs. The FBI
identifying the gunman as 36-year-old
Mohammad Diallo, a former Virginia
National Guard member. Around 10:45
Thursday morning, investigators say he
calmly walked into a classroom on
campus, asked if it was the ROTC, and
when someone said yes, he shot the
instructor several times. A third victim
who died identified late today as US
Army Lieutenant Colonel Brandon Shaw, a
veteran Army aviator who was a professor
of military science at ODU, where he was
also an alum. And he specifically
targeted these ROTC students. He
actually asked somebody, "Is this the
ROTC class?" before going in and opening
fire. He first shot the teacher as he
broke into the class, then he fired on
the students, and this is really
incredible. The students fought back. In
fact, they, the students, are the ones
who subdued him. One of those students
happened to have a knife, and the FBI
said they killed him.
It's awesome that the ROTC students
stopped him before he could kill more
people, but I see three glaring problems
here.
One, you can have a Muslim serving in
the military or working somewhere else
who believes in Islam but doesn't know
much about what it teaches.
That Muslim can start watching lectures
online and decide to go on a killing
spree.
How do you know which Muslims are going
to go on killing sprees?
You don't.
All you know is that you're not allowed
to say it has anything to do with Islam.
Two, when a Muslim decides to go on a
killing spree but gets caught before he
kills anyone, all he has to do in court
is say that it wasn't really because of
Islam, it was because of a bad breakup
or a bad meal or a bad experience at
work or drugs or climate change, and the
judge will buy it.
Why?
Because that judge has been told all his
life or all her life that Islam is a
religion of peace and tolerance. So,
when a Muslim decides to kill people, it
must be for some other reason.
If you're a jihadi and you get caught,
just tell the judge what he or she wants
to hear and you'll be heading home soon
enough.
Three, Muhammad Diallo was arrested
before his first killing spree ever
started.
But this time, he actually killed
someone.
Why didn't he get stopped early this
time? Especially when he had already
been convicted of providing material
support to ISIS.
Why didn't authorities stop him
beforehand this time?
Because he learned his lesson after his
first plot.
He had years in prison to think about
where he'd gone wrong, namely blabbing
his plans to other people.
His first arrest, trial, and conviction
simply taught him to be more careful
next time.
Guess what, ladies and gentlemen?
There are lots of jihadis in prisons
and they've got release dates.
And they've learned not to make the same
mistakes that got them arrested the
first time.
Now, another victim of jihad is dead and
Muhammad Diallo is dead.
How do we stop this?
I say, stop protecting Islam from
criticism and make the criticisms common
knowledge so that by the time people
like Muhammad Diallo find out what Islam
teaches, they've already got some
reasons not to take it too seriously.
But my approach is Islamophobic, so we
can't do that.
Instead, we have to continue praising
Islam and pretending it's wonderful, so
people like Muhammad Diallo never have
any reason to doubt it.
Then they start watching the videos and
people die.
The people who die are basically
offerings on the altar of our God
tolerance.
Much like the tens of thousands of
British girls who were groomed and raped
were offerings on that altar.
Offering up men and women and children
to prove our devotion to some new God.
We kind of sound like
pagans, don't we?
Who's dying on that?
Who's dying on that? Who's dying on
that?
It just popped finally. Who's dying on
Who's dying on that?
It just popped finally. This is a
problem with religion. There's a reason
to it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?